maíz de todos los colores ají gusanillo
y pescados autóctonos un festín de
colores y aromas para celebrar la
diversidad gastronómica de la amazonia
peruana y boliviana los chefs marciata y
Virgilio Martínez combinaron sus
talentos para trasladar la biodiversidad
de esta región a los platos de un
prestigioso restaurante de la ciudad de
la paz en Bolivia vemos no que hay una
cultura
latinoamericana muy fuerte no que quiere
preservar su identidad que quiere
preservar su cultura ancestral
su cultura es productos
y que quieres este realmente
no solo cocinar por por cocinar
impresionar sino quieres trascender con
lo que haces para esa colaboración
utilizaron la información recopilada por
el proyecto Sabores silvestres de la
chef boliviana que a lo largo de 15 años
de investigación con comunidades
indígenas de la amazonía ha registrado
centenares de ingredientes hemos
trabajado con alrededor de 200
comunidades indígenas con más de 600
productos registrados y con los que
hemos trabajado también en el
restaurante y bueno para nosotros es un
orgullo Y esto es una celebración No
solamente la amazonía ya lo
biodiversidad pero también a nuestros
productores más que un catálogo de
ingredientes nativos y técnicas
culinarias el proyecto Sabores
silvestres también colabora con
productores indígenas así apoyan
económicamente a esas comunidades que
tratan de preservar un ecosistema
excepcional pero gravemente amenazado